okay so a woman in pennsylvania
is actually arrested because she's
trying to terrorize
teenagers and their parents who are a
part of her daughter's cheer team
she's trying to make like intimidate
these uh
cheerleaders from dropping out and from
competing
in competition so her daughter has more
uh like performance time you know
and she's doing
[Applause]
no she's not keto um but she
actually used deep fake technology to
put faces of these teenagers onto like
photos of other people smoking drinking
or even nude
and then she sent it to them saying like
if you don't
drop out i'm gonna send these out or i'm
going to report you
what a [ __ ] idiot yeah yo like those
hey do they have any of your samples or
no
no i know yeah i want to see you these
are underrated
we're not good it's just really bad
there's like a slight lag and everything
yeah
no chair moms are [ __ ] nuts about
like wanting their kid
to like shine dan's mom's a lifetime
they're so serious
yeah dance moms yeah same [ __ ] they're
literally moms compete
hey how many of them uh cheer moms when
you're teaching those kids try to get
ahold of that
chocolate stick what i'm not kissing too
you know i'm sure a couple of moms were
looking there liking
hey right you leave me alone
i wasn't thick back then i was in shape
i was in shape
yeah i'm sure did you just train their
kids
bro look at that mom if i could just
give me some chapelle
so this is another high school one where
a high school principal
uh has a 17 year old daughter who goes
to the school that she is the principal
of
they actually caught the mother and
daughter hacking into students accounts
so the daughter would win homecoming
queens these [ __ ] people
but also i like how the police did a
whole
crimes investigation you could be
focusing on
this [ __ ] lady that's true i just
want my daughter to be [ __ ] prom
queen
too and what happens to them i guess
she's getting arrested for hacking into
the system okay listen all that for
homecoming queen
what the [ __ ] listen to grades get me to
college
yeah great [ __ ] homie yeah [ __ ] that
[ __ ] man that's just for the crap yeah
that's right
listen you're a parent yeah right you
love your kids
yeah would you do anything
it's so embarrassing isn't it [ __ ]
embarrassing
to think like oh man my my kid deserves
this
i'm gonna [ __ ] hack
i get it you love your kids and [ __ ] i
get it but like
i mean if my kid is not homecoming queen
then [ __ ] it you suck i mean i'm not
saying you suck
both of them you just lost yeah take the
[ __ ] l but like
but even homecoming king or queen like
what's it do
but also yeah who gives a [ __ ] cares
i wonder if your daughter was popular at
all
because what if it's just like some like
some shy like nerdy girl who like didn't
get any attention then suddenly she's
like homecoming
the whole school figure for her they'd
be like yeah
maybe it's a mistrial
hold on now let's recap the votes she's
like the worst looking one
y'all sure i just see them announcing it
just like is
even the principal was like i don't know
so bad
before your homecoming queen is damn
is this right did you guys get voted for
homecoming or problem
i hated everybody my sister was promised
that was too crazy
cat no never chin no
did you you you seemed like i got voted
for uh
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey i appreciate i appreciate you all
voting make sure your chips and guaca
totally
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
don't hurt him not daddy that was a
freshman oh he was a freshman he's a
freshman
oh what was it for homecoming uh prom
homecoming
king oh okay as a freshman damn
you know homecoming is better in prime
because homecoming you get to ride
around that field and the cars and stuff
like that oh yeah
yeah yeah i was too shy though i didn't
go on the parade
i was like i was embarrassed so i didn't
do it oh because yeah they put the
nominated nominees like half time i was
like i'm trying to play a football game
going on that [ __ ]
wagon or what the [ __ ] that always
tripped me up
trying to play football you got your
principal on the horn
all right vote for
we see you out there brenden good job
good job he's on the field right now
he's playing the game real well
those things are so strange it's weird
can you remember who won
do you know the names of the kids who
won never oh dude no not a [ __ ]
clue i don't even know where they're at
now nah yeah
it's such a rig though i'm kudos to that
pair and i'm thinking it's such a rigged
system
most popular kid always wins yeah
but the girl the most popular she'll go
up to people she'll never talk to like
hey i'm running against politics
same [ __ ] yeah you're right it's no
different there's paul taken
yeah wait wait wait what were you trying
to say because i said the popular yeah
they're gonna vote for the most popular
person but [ __ ]
but she should win though she's popular
in her crew then she goes outside her
crew
and make the nerves feel good they don't
care about no we had some bad [ __ ]
who were nice people that won
oh we're like they're like super they're
like our [ __ ]
you know cardi b like everywhere their
tits were big because they had huge
hearts
oh yeah big titties big hearts right
all yep [ __ ] how about that when i get
off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son